paul we're curious what prompted you to
make
a road trip movie where you say on your
website four guys stuffed in a small van
with rolls of film
seeing where the road would take them
what prompted this sounds like quite a
good line actually who came out with
that
um um what prompted us to make this film
um basically curiosity at the time as to
how americans felt about america
and and really i was curious about that
because i didn't know how i felt about
america at that time
i was struggling i've always loved
america ever since i was a kid you know
and um at that time i was sort of
struggling with the economic downturn
and the way that this american dream had
sort of fallen in on itself and
the sort of hell-bent pursuit of
material goods consumption all these
things supposed to make you happy and i
was like well hang on this isn't
quite working is it it's just fallen
flat on its face that whole notion
and i wasn't too sure how i was feeling
about america but i thought before i
really formed an opinion i should
perhaps speak to
more of the people out of out of america
outside of the areas that i spend most
of my time i.e
new york los angeles east and west coast
in those areas
so i've sort of wanted to get into the
sort of the heartland of america and
speak to the people out there especially
the ones that gets
that those areas that get such a hard
you know they get a lot of rap about oh
you know
just fly over country and bible belt and
you know rust belt and stuff like no
there's something going on there i want
to speak to these people
and so i felt if i spoke to those people
the main the people of the heart of
america
i'd be able to form a better opinion how
i felt about america at that time
so that's what i did we just got on the
road and um with those rolls of film and
and drove across america and interviewed
lots of very interesting characters